here we got someone's lying come on then
you had the constitution
let me try more go ahead your mouth's
way on your absolute miles away
i vaccinate absolutely not all right
here can here come the questions people
are asking that i'm not pro-vaccine that
i'm not pro-medicine
i just believe pro evidence somebody who
wants to get for instance mercury out of
fish he's not anti-fish
explain the difference between ingestion
and injection
damn cookie diet coke right here so if
you stay away from coke then stay away
from vaccines that's what you're saying
it's nice to hook up with you and
talk about a very important topic that's
uh
you actually have been talking about for
some time
and for people that don't know you're a
professor
teacher teacher at the uh maghrib
institute correct
but you also have a lot of stake in the
game you're a pharmacist
right you're someone who uh tell us
about that
so yeah i'm a pharmacist so i read
pharmacy
um at university and then i went into
when you read pharmacy then you can go
into different uh specialities
when you think of a pharmacist normally
it's
you know effectively the one who
dispenses checks or prescriptions in
a neighborhood kind of pharmacy or shop
for extensive purposes
then you've got a small percentage that
go into manufacturing and industry which
is what i did my first year and then
those that go into um um
quality control making sure that you
know injections and
uh iv preparations are good and
above board and then those who are
clinical which are those who are based
in hospital
that would accompany doctors um and uh
deal with
various units myself was the neo-native
the neonatal intensive care unit that's
where i did my training
so i'm a clinical pharmacist in terms of
my qualification but i did i
did it all then i also was involved in
medicines
um never vaccines per se and
obviously that's big money big big
business that is but um
uh medication i had my own um
uh cream i had a couple of my own
products as well that were marketed
abroad
et cetera et cetera so yeah i've got my
fingers in when it comes to pharmacy and
medicines
um across the board from community to
clinical to manufacturing so i guess
that's right and then obviously from an
islamic point of view
um my islamic qualification means that i
will
teach and speak about medication
in principle the islamic point of view
and then of course
islam has a i don't want to say that
greater emphasis because
clearly from the western or the secular
side there's a huge emphasis in the
right places on holistic medication
whether
it's non-systemic or not not ingested
such as such as acupuncture or such as
copying which is
pre-islamic by thousands of years but
then also
holistic it's another big push for uh
more kind of a healthy living something
that you've obviously been promoting for
a long time
that kind of thing is very in line with
the islamic side so
i guess i could say i could argue that
when it comes to medicines
i will come at it at every possible
conceivable angle
and that's the beautiful thing about our
deen and i'm sure a lot of people
who are not yet muslim non-muslim
whatever you want to call it
you know tune in and see what these
muslims have to you know say about
health and vaccines and all these other
things and
and islam is a and then also maybe learn
a little bit about islam you know what i
mean from our conversation
and what got me motivated uh years ago
to talk more about this
is is to bring to the table the
discussion about health you know and i
started to bring out experts just like
you know i wanted to share the dean this
beautiful way of life so i brought on
experts you know scholars and
and hear people's stories and to clear
much of the fog the misunderstanding
much of the
the misinformation and a lot of it was
deliberate and and let people
judge for themselves what muslims are
what islam is all about but then also
health you know it's a part of our
health we have uh
so many as you know you know hadith
talking about the thing that people take
for granted the most time and
health right and what good are you what
good am i if our health
is declining you know how we're going to
get out there and how are people going
to get out there and make a difference
in the world so i started to bring on
to motivate us to get the coca-colas out
of the masjids right
so you know to start starting hey i'm
dying
amanda we're gutted man that trump has
been kicked out and he lost his diet
coke but we're guided at that here in
the uk man that was amazing
right and the first thing he does man he
gets rid of that [ __ ] button can you do
something else instead of get rid of
that
through the heart carry on bro yeah so
so we wanted to i
for my personal journey i saw that you
know i was uh really into working out
martial artists and that but i was just
eating whatever i wanted to eat i
thought that was you know it was okay as
long as i was working out but
then i lo and behold you know going to
the doctor and just you know
demanding the antibiotics you know give
me something for it you know you're
convinced uh
pill for every ill but then lo and
behold these things you know at the end
other problems start coming up and the
you're not getting to the root of the
problem
and then you see that man allah god
almighty allah has given us these
beautiful taibat foods you know that
really you know make a difference you
know
then you see the science behind the
foods and you hook up with you know
uh people who specializes in this and
then tremendous thing happens you know
you watch the documentaries i don't know
if you've ever seen uh
fat sick and almost dead you you
remember that one isn't that amazing
you remember that right he's amazing
absolutely it's amazing he's on like 12.
i want to i want to comment on that as a
bread yeah obviously i don't know how
many bricks you have on your show
but that would also be interesting if
the majority of your viewership is
american
then that will be an interesting uh uh
corollary
that from our points of view from the
brits and maybe i can even argue
a lot of the rest of the world or maybe
arrested a lot of the rest of the
developing world maybe you speak for
europe
maybe not look maybe not for this the
more natural kind of east
but when we look at america one of the
interesting things that we
notice is that there are certain
historical developments
and practical geographical realities
about america
that very much shape this attitude to
everything you're talking about today so
for example
an appeal for every ill right this
is frankly in the uk which obviously has
a national
national health service right where you
don't pay
essentially well not directly indirectly
of course but not directly pay for
your health care unlike in the us in the
us
you can understand the the skepticism
the cynicism towards doctors and them
wanting to
make money um because you know they've
got to be shown to be
giving something back if you pay for 2
300 to see a guy for a few minutes
and then you don't even get something
out of it at the end of it you feel like
cheated so you know there's a
that's going to eventually play on your
psyche it's going to develop a certain
state of mind
here if you can imagine um
much of the national health service is
based upon the principle to try not to
give action in medicine
now that's not because they are high in
mighty or moral ethics but just the
finances of the matter
right so you'll see a vast difference
between when you go for private care and
i
i've used private care and i know about
the private care scene even though i'm
in the uk
but the national health service which is
while working and i've used most
majority of my life my family's life
right there is a big difference and it's
no surprise that
doctors and pharmacists even themselves
as being the kind of you know the
proponents of medication
are the ones who use medicines least
themselves
and they will be trying their very best
to get
people not to be taking antibiotics
we're very big on antibiotic resistance
for example because of the
overuse of antibiotics cold season flu
season people come give me something for
this dog to give me some production
hey bro this is a viral infection you
can't cure it
you can't cure a viral infection we
don't have a cure for it or a medicine
for it
and me giving an answer for a bacterial
infection is not going to help a viral
infection
so we actually have a very different
philosophy because of our finances our
politics and so on
whereas in america you can understand
people being super cynical it's not
pakistan it's not where my ethnic
background is
people are very very suspicious when
they go to a doctor and doctor writes
about a whole load of medicines
you will see them go and negotiate all
the time by the way
with the pharmacist when they take the
prescription in and say what do i
actually really need here
what actually do i really need from this
i want and you would negotiate with the
pharmacist
10 20 of what you were given in the
first place
so that has an impact and then in
america you guys have the ability to
hunt go out and eat fresh food massive
country crazy kind of scenery
once you've tasted natural proper food
you're like you're a country that can
produce virtually everything not a
little
useless island like us have to import
everything right okay
you guys make your own food you've got
people who grow their own food lots of
you know rural size farm sites that has
an impact because people see it working
so it's not just theory and crackpoint
ideas that i'm going off the grid
yeah if you said i'm going off the grid
in the uk we think that you've lost your
mind
in the u.s it's a very real thing add to
that the fear of big pharma
big government don't want to you know so
it actually fits very well in america a
lot of these kind of
mindsets and ways which the rest of the
world can sometimes
unfairly if they don't understand this
development not kind of get to the crux
of and understand why
their cynicism comes or where their
criticism comes from and that i'd like
to discuss that a bit later in the
program yeah
yeah so you can see where we uh
then i i had you know watching
documentaries like that and others and
then talking to uh
to doctors kind of doctors who were i
kind of compared to like
let's say you have someone who finished
a madrasa or
let's say specialize in one little area
but then someone who went and studied
let's say all the meth
right and just as open-minded you know
what i mean and his mind is because
we have to be always learning so then
you have doctors who because as you know
we know when i asked him when i learned
that doctors in medical school
this is just a fact they don't learn
about nutrition
is that correct right you know that's
good but then there's doctors
then there's doctors that go out and so
they graduate from the
traditional medical schooling and then
they go out and they still
continue to learn they learn nutrition
so i bring on doctors like this and we
talk about you know
we talk about these things and then
always somewhere in the equation you
know because it's big here there
everywhere
is the the topic of vaccines right that
comes up
and so then now i wanted to i wanted to
put for some time we've been trying to
get
you know two parties together now i
myself
uh i'm not uh anti-vaccine i'm not you
know because i don't like
you know in many people they put these
labels you know you get these
anti-vaxxer this that and the other
but then you have you know people who
are just sincerely trying to i'm i'm uh
i'm for safe you know like somebody who
wants to get for instance mercury out of
fish he's not anti-fish
right so you want you want to you want
to make sure what you're putting in your
body is safe
it's truly safe so you have uh people
who question certain things and then
they get labeled you know and you have a
lot of
a lot of family members who are just you
know pro
all the way blindly following you know
the doctors and then next thing you know
they lost their child and it's not one
case two kids these are thousands of
cases we have
really a lot of parents who are
concerned so we wanted to get to the
bottom of things and
you know invite someone a doctor from
this side a doctor from that side a
specialist from this side that
and just to talk to kind of get to the
you know to the nitty-gritty and really
to find ask those questions and see
where because our dean encourages us to
learn so i wanted to i almost had
something set up
you convinced me you motivated me that
it would just be me and you
but i thought it'd be interesting to
have you i had dr sherry tenpenny she's
one
she's a medical doctor board certified
who had forty thousand
uh out forty thousand hours of research
uh and i thought it would have been
really just nice to see you guys not you
know and i was really serious about just
us together asking questions and you
know
you can agree to disagree on some things
but let the audience those who are
sincere
you know really looking let them to
evaluate you know to use what allah
gave us god might give us of our brains
to look and to dissect and to see
you know where the truth is you know
as i said to you um that's the
theory in the real world there are no
people at this moment in
time that are i shall lie in the middle
that are
looking to see the rights and wrongs or
whatever as you as you said people are
incredibly polarized
um i never over many many years of dawah
mean you are of the same generation
uh 20 30 years in the game i never
saw any benefit come from any debate all
i saw was people coming off with an
incredible adrenaline buzz
people johnny really on a high their
side has won
and that is not conducive to my uh my
intention
like for example my intention here very
clearly in this
uh conversation is and i've given
i think two major public presentations
on this
thus far focusing on different things
each time
also focusing on different vaccines each
time so now fish freshening has been
covered the dirt has been covered
principles for tower whatever one of my
main aims
in this one i would argue is
uh oh i i in my head that's how it's
working out is i want to show
just how islamically this
mindset uh is a problem that develops
the plandemic
narrative the um the anti
everything this extreme skepticism that
we're finding and whether that fits with
our profile as practicing muslims um
that is something which i do not see
conducive in a debate versus vaccine
non-vaccine blah blah blah
like you said you don't describe
yourself as an anti-vaxxer i also
very much do not describe myself as a
pro-vaxxer in actual fact
um other than ac acwi which is a
meningitis vaccine because i
lead hygiene omro groups um other than
that
the clovid vaccine is the first vaccine
that i've taken in donkey's ears
right um and i spoke a little bit about
that maybe we can
uh discuss you know the approach to
different vaccines and whether we should
see them differently
because they when you talk to people on
you know on other side like myself i
would say
you know i'm for type type vaccines if
there's such a thing you know what it
means
and there is such a thing right because
you know a lot of people have got to be
careful
right um as you said at the beginning
you know that there are people who just
wanted to try and find out
and not everybody is a hater not
everybody although right now
my biggest problem are those who spread
lies and that's unacceptable and
fabrication and that for me
is a very very personal thing because
ultimately
uh if allah listen to listen if forget
about you and me
if allah has not obligated vaccines upon
a person
right how can we say anything against a
person who then says
i'd rather not and i'd rather x or
otherwise our problem is those people
who spread fabrication and lies that's a
major
major problem and islamically muslims
can never
stand for them um and when it comes to
failure
as i did in the first lecture that i
gave on this
we are muslims are the developers of the
concept of vaccination
inoculation came with us i mean yeah the
chinese had a
kind of basic primitive form but when it
came to smallpox and the attack on
smallpox
muslims are the ones we dealt with the
ottoman empire are the ones who smashed
it
and then it was taken by edwin edward
jenner and it was turned into
you know the official form but all of
these
vaccination schemes they were asleep as
it comes
if you are defining pure and good
purely from an excipient point of view
and this is the problem definitions
right
if you think that by you right because
normally when we have the discussion of
halal
this is we understand that those who are
switched switched on
understand that food just can't be halal
you can't yeah you know keep a a
a sheep or eggs or chickens locked up in
the thingy and destroy them mentally and
socially and you know
hormones all over them and feed them all
nonsense and just say
this that's uh
[Music]
who it has to be animal needs to be
treated adam there has to be no fear
there shouldn't be
stuff full of antibiotics from all the
rubbish that we we do so that's how
people normally understand
the dichotomy of halal and we want both
we want
healthy halal food when it comes to
vaccines and medicines
we can't be so lazy it's a different
uh paradigm what do we mean by
do we mean anything in addition to the
actual
uh active ingredient well that's just
not going to be possible in the modern
world today it's just not possible to
just
transport around a inactivated or mild
form of a virus
a natural virus and give it back like
the muslims started off with
you start off small scale where you take
a pustule of the actual
infection and you re-infect at a smaller
level
which is inoculation that's as fabulous
as it gets if you are defining failure
as no mercury no ethanol no x not
because it's nothing
right it's literally you're taking the
same thing and putting it back in but
today if we were to use that then
actually
we can't eat anything we can't drink
anything we can't take any medicine
because it's not possible just to have
the pure active ingredient
by itself it you know the idea of
aluminium for example a lot of
discussion that aluminium is a poison
and a metal that what you know etc
it's an adjuvant aluminium like it is in
our natural body like it is when it
exists in food as well it its function
is not to be
it's not its function is not to be eaten
or swallowed in of itself
it's part and parcel of ensuring that
the other thing the second the primary
thing
is getting to your system or or whatever
so it is important for us that
our lofty principles our ethics which
are really
focused on does not cloud our mind to
think
that we have the same concept of even
food in vaccinations
or in vaccines or in medicines or in
other fields even
you know parts of life so you have
people here who classify themselves as
pro-science
they're for safe vaccines first of all
you started out by
introducing is anti-vaccine which i'm
not
people say i'm anti-vaccine because they
don't want to have the argument with me
about
how to improve vaccines and i'm
i'm on a vaccine i'm i'm
i believe we should have safe vaccines
and i believe we should have robust
science
and i believe that we should have
independent regulators who are not
financially tied to the companies that
make our vaccines
you know pro-common sense you know and
even you see people who
many doctors who come and they they're
they just want to
let's say delay the vaccine they want to
spread them out so we've seen an attack
even on those people
who just go against the schedule and
whatnot so
let's start off with this so you do have
we uh
people would agree that okay like you
just said that if they've done the
research uh because we see also this
demonizing where people
say uh yeah well you you'll see you'll
see people like
make a fringe element of people uh as if
they represent
you know what this group of scientist
doctors
is representing for instance i'll give
you example they'll come out and say
oh you think you're going to take this
jab and turn into a frog you know what i
mean some are just some ridiculous
statements maybe someone said that but
it's just way out there
but you do have we have to admit you do
have qualified
virologists immunologists you know
scientists
on on on this other side and those are
the people we're trying to get to talk
so i guess that's the first question
why is it that you know my my guest that
i had last time
she even they even put up a hundred
thousand dollars they had a backing of a
hundred thousand dollars to get
people to step up and let's have this
dialogue if you
they're they're saying so now i'm gonna
be the skeptic okay i'm gonna be the
person look because i'm in the middle
you motivated me to come it's just me
and you
so i kind of like i'm in the middle all
right so i'm i'm saying this is what
the other side is saying you know so
don't have me as picking sides i'm just
the skeptic here i'm saying i'm trying
to relay the information it'd be nice to
have someone so they can just speak
directly
but now they're saying why don't they
debate why don't they come up if they if
they feel like we're
they're the quacks if they're the
anti-science if you have truth on this
side you know
like we in islam we have and here's a
mixture people can we're doing dao at
the same time we have tahit for instance
let's talk whoever it is to heed what
god almighty says in the quran when
truth is
thrown against falsehood falsehood by
his nature is weak is bound to perish
so if you're on the truth let's talk
about it you know but let's have some
perimeters not to insult not to defile
let's be academic about it
so that i guess that's the first
question why what's the on on this side
they won't even come and have these
debates and talk which to me speaks
volumes because if they are so right
and so sure that they are so right
wouldn't you love to have an opportunity
to take dr sherry ten penny on a public
stage in front of everybody
and put a heel of your boot to her neck
and bury her once and for all
because the thing is that to shut it
down there's no reason to
if if you're scientists let's see let's
hear that everybody doesn't seem to want
to hear much about it
it's shut down and you guys are the ones
that should be the investigating
do the investigating so from my side i
can tell you
not you i'm saying i'm saying yeah i
know but i just want to say something
from my side i just want to say straight
off that i never knew that they offered
a hundred thousand
they give me a hundred thousand dollars
yeah i will be there tonight
not even next week you tell that person
of yours yeah who said
a hundred thousand dollars you never
told me a hundred thousand grand
hundred grand come on bro okay hundred
grand
i'm there bro put my name down it's
signed
that's the answer to your second your
first question beautiful second question
bro
i'm doing it for free i'm not going to
go waste my time against a person that i
know
is going to waste my time and that's
that's that's the reality
debates as i said to you before if we're
going to be serious i never
there's a big difference between the
establishments of evidence
and the the uh ref the reputation
of uh falsehood and of what we consider
falsehood without any disrespect
especially when it's something which is
well done many many years
like uh 10 doctor 10 penny this is not
something new she's not a
coveted denier she's someone who has
history
understands the concept of vaccinations
and has an opinion of vaccinations she's
not changing that opinion
she's not going to just like i am not
going to change the opinion of
vaccinations on the signs covet did
nothing by the way for my pro
or or anti vaccine approach
i've never been a massive fan of
medicines full stop
right i take very little medicines so
nobody was going to come and make me
take medicines anymore
i teach the the subject of medicines i
am a promoter of the opinion that it is
only permissible
many scholars today are it's obligated
to take medicines
medicines save people's lives as a
medicine expert i know what medicines do
medicines aren't as rated as people make
them out to be
so i don't need to have a discussion or
debate with people who are trying to
teach me that which i already know
there's a big difference between
the the platform of debate the platform
of
debate being uh used to reach someone's
objective
or a particular objective versus that
which is trying to benefit people
that which is actually trying to uh uh
reach the truth per se but let me just
make it clear a hundred grand makes that
whole concept yes
very murky i would completely throw that
to the side
and tell your friend whoever it was or
your guest i'm ready for that
hundred percent okay let me get more
details on that because
yeah more details on that i don't know i
don't know if that was qualified i don't
know if that was specific for like the
paul
office don't you even think about
backtracking now bro
this ain't no chicago behavior bro this
is how we do in england when a man
says his word it's his word okay a
hundred grand i'm ready bro
off my side i'll give him a chocolate
bar okay dr sherry penny if you're
watching this we're gonna have
she'll be back on the show soon so uh
she's gonna be getting the message for
you
okay so now look here's an example
that's given
it's like would you so we get to the
root of the matter because you have
science here you have peer route studies
you know on both sides and
now one side is calling out the other
saying and we're just having a heart to
heart trying to get to
to the bottom of things but what what i
what i see potentially maybe is one side
missing something you know what i mean
uh the whole spectrum of the of the
matter for instance uh let's go
let's go to this question now if you
knew that someone was a like a
i don't know if you've heard of uh
bernie murdoch
oh yeah you know him he swindled people
out of billions of dollars right
or the mafia or someone who was a serial
felon now they used four companies
that make all of our vaccines all 72 of
the vaccine shots that are now mandated
for our children
every one of them is a convicted serial
felon axo sanofi
in the past 10 years just in the last
decade
those companies have paid 35 billion
dollars in criminal penalties
damages fines are lying to doctors for
defrauding science for
falsifying science for killing hundreds
of thousands of americans
knowingly right would you with this
person
his track fragrance knowing that he has
skimmed scam people
would you invest your life savings with
this person
money financially that individual of
course not
people like that and personally no no no
no not people
of course i would because people are not
represented by a person
yeah and this is the issue eddie yeah
okay this is why
this conversation is an absolute
humiliation for muslims to discuss
you see non-muslims no problem i would
discuss with non-muslims this concept
because from their principles which are
very limited in scope
are secular in in basis not based in the
divine
where our set of principles and our
methodology our manhattan
is entirely different we do not judge a
system or a belief or a group
or a people you know the question you
know what i'm so you know you know what
i'm getting to this is what because this
is what the contention obviously there
are certain people
that are important that are
representatives of certain shields
here's what they're saying what's being
said is that so now if we wouldn't trust
you know our life savings to a criminal
organization
now you have for instance you know the
four major
uh pharmaceutical companies who are
serial felons
they have been criminally like i
explained in my first lecture
pfizer and it's absolute most corrupt
well so we're not we're we agree we're
not talking about someone i mentioned
earlier for for people
when i said tohit i forgot to mention
that's the pure monotheism you know
because as muslims we only worship one
and only one god the same way jesus
moses and abraham did so
that's what i was talking about the
truth is clear in this matter but now we
also have toba if someone
you know there's no blood sacrifice
going through anybody this that and the
other you go
directly to your creator so if you made
toba if you repented
right you could see the worst you know
the best in the or the worst in the deen
become
in the dunya can become the best uh
deliverers of truth
so we're not talking about people like
that who have made
repentance you know what i mean we're
talking about everything that
criminality is
exactly so that's the point how do we
trust this is my point this is
how do we trust you let me just finish
this point how do we trust
serial felons you know with our children
with our health these are not moral
companies
and they only got busted because
plaintiff's attorneys could sue them
very very
and they got the discovery documents and
walked them down to the u.s attorney's
office and said hey there's criminal
behavior here
that can never happen in the vaccine
space because you can't sue them there's
no discovery there's no depositions
there's no
class action suit there's no
multi-discipline on district litigation
there's no
interrogatories nothing they never get
caught you know to be giving them a
blade that's we don't yeah
and that we don't neither islamically do
we
and neither does the world of science
now if once a in an independent
individual let alone an independent
body or an advisory body or a national
regulatory agency or regulatory standard
bodies
do that and they are the ones who are
taking responsibility
and absolutely so that's what something
which we demand and then the other side
then
come back and say well actually they are
all individually linked you saw this
person do this
you saw this person do that and he used
to work with this and he used to work
with that
and so on and so forth if we're going to
if we if we believe that character
assassination
has to be the hustle has to be the basis
of trying to ensure or prove your point
that
actually there is not a single honest
person
left in the world because of the
corruption of said company or because of
the
well-known crimes and fraud
and falsification of evidences
falsification of data
things that listen come to me for that
information i know that i've released
drugs
i know who which countries to go to to
have clinical trials in
which ones will turn one way turn the
other one it's well known why the who
looks down their nose in a
to use a phrase at certain countries
uh certification of meditation and
doesn't look that way
at other countries certain uh regulation
and whatever
because the game is the game everybody
knows what's going on
the idea that there is some mass
conspiracy
where every single criminal entity
uh pharma company that has committed a
crime at some time or whatever
represents all of the people who are
involved in that
it's not just an embarrassing claim from
a secular
news you know just a reality point of
view but islamically it is
utterly untenable it's completely
unacceptable
for muslims to act and speak in this way
otherwise there's no point living life
because you might as well now suspect
everything that moves yeah because if
you start to believe
that everyone and every person who has
been put forward in a position of
responsibility is all part of some cabal
because that's all and that's what
people have got to accept if your guests
and your people are
making that initial step and then going
on that's where it ends
and this is not our deen so i don't mind
non-muslims coming out with this kind of
nonsense but i will refuse
to allow muslims to claim that and then
to go on and practice as practicing
muslims and make out that this is
actually an islamically tenable position
it's just completely unacceptable but
this is i don't know if you're familiar
with the work of uh
robert f kennedy jr have you he has the
children's healthcare
in which in which area i i know of him
yeah okay uh yeah he
he was uh he's uh you know he's the
nephew of the
former president united states and he's
uh also a
environmental activist his story is that
people started coming up to me at that
time mainly women with
children who had intellectual
disabilities who
were vaccine injured and they'd come up
to me and say
if you're really concerned about mercury
exposures to children you need to look
at vaccines
and i didn't want to do it you know my
family has been involved in the
issues of intellectual disabilities for
generations yeah
it's something i grew up with i care
deeply about but i wanted to spend my
time protecting water
one of these women came to me on cape
cod
and at the end of 2004 she had a big
pile of scientific studies and she put
them on my
front stoop and she was a psychologist
from minnesota her name was dr sauer
bridges
her son had been a perfectly healthy boy
an autism from a vaccine the vaccine
court had
acknowledged that that was true and
given him a 20 million dollar settlement
and she put this pile on my front step
and she said i'm not leaving here so you
read those and
i'm very accustomed to reading science
it's part of my job i've brought
hundreds of lawsuits they all involve
scientific contrary
i started reading that science and i was
immediately struck
by the huge delta between what the
actual science was saying and what the
public health issues
and this is the last thing he wanted to
get involved in the last thing you know
he was
suing companies like monsanto and
whatnot so he saw the corruption from
within he gives a story of how you know
the epa who's a government uh regulatory
agency is supposed to be monitoring
people like you know monsanto and
whatnot but but then they were going
over this uh
they were suing them because i think
there's glyphosate you know it's a
carcinogen causing cancer or whatnot now
the epa is saying
their experts are coming on and saying
no it doesn't cause cancer
uh robert f kennedy wins the case and
then they find out that the epa
they actually they the head of the ap
was epa was working
it was working with monsanto right so
the agency was actually captured
you had you said we have to rely on the
majority
well i grew up in the state of virginia
alan
when i grew up it was illegal the
majority voted
that it was illegal for a black man to
marry a white woman
so the majority is not now in a
democracy you have the courts
um and unfortunately we are in a
situation today
where we have tremendous corruption not
only in congress which is receiving
which receives more money from
pharmaceutical companies than any other
industry
pharmaceutical gifts in lobbying twice
the amount that oil and gas which is the
next big one
four times what defense and aerospace
there are more lobbyists
armed lobbyists in congress and there
are members of congress in the senate so
we have lost the um
you know the legislative independent of
that body
and the unfortunately alan
let the agencies are also captured
now you know about agency capture
it happens everywhere and the i
my entire life we just i'm pursued the
the uh epa we just did monsanto
we got an historic judgement 12 billion
dollar settlement in the monsanto case
and i was part of that trial team and
one of the things that happened during
that trial
is that epa took a position against us
they took a position that
that i glyphosate as i round up this i
caused cancer
as it turns out we got internal
memorandum that showed that the head of
the pesticide division
in epa was actually working secretly for
monsanto
and killing studies and twisting studies
and ghost writing studies
to falsify the science so now he's
he starts to he went through he went
through this literature that she had and
he would just
you know he was uh shocked you know what
i mean and and this
woke up the truth you know woke up his
conscious so then he started to go down
that rabbit hole as you call it he
started looking at
you know uh this even even deeper and
then he started to see
you know for instance the fda 50 of his
budget comes from vaccine companies cdc
11.5
billion of a budget you know they have
4.9
billion is in buying and selling
vaccines imagine this
a cpa which is an independent agency
imagine this
fda that's 50 of its budget
from vaccine companies from the industry
50
the cdc
has an 11.5 billion dollar budget and
4.9 billion of that
is buying and selling and distributing
vaccines
cdc is a vaccine company it owns 57
vaccine patents
so it can make money on every sale of a
vaccine
nih owns hundreds of vaccine patents
nih owns half the patent for the modern
vaccine so he started to see you know
the great conflicts of interest he would
see you know
people who are working for the vax for
the uh
for the pharmaceutical company or the uh
cdc next do you know they come out and
they start working they have a nice
position at the uh
at the at pharma you know what i mean so
he started to see
all these contradict the conflicts of
interest and he calls it out so i bring
him up because
uh this is he he starts to point out and
show you know
when a person sees how they call it the
sausage is being made
they see all the corruption behind so
now obviously
you know and there's another great
example given i don't know if you've
seen this
documentary called vaxxed have you seen
the documentary
yeah you've seen it yes you listen let
me just finish this let me just finish
yeah i'm really i'm happy that you watch
something like this because i really
think
you know this is something that everyone
should see i think the movie
is something that people should see
there was a backlash which
i haven't fully explored and i will but
definitely there's something to that
movie and there's another movie called
trace amounts
and these there there's a lot of
information about things that are
happening with the cdc
the pharmaceutical companies there's a
lot of things that are not said
i as a parent of a child who has autism
i'm concerned
and i want to know the truth and i'm not
anti-vaccine
i want safe vaccines when you get some
people can't get a a
a certain type of shot and they can die
from it
you know even penicillin so why should
that not be with vaccine which it isn't
that one is is revolves around a
scientist the senior scientist dr
william
thomas you know they are not doing their
job
as regulators and in fact the senior
scientist
at cdc today the senior vaccine safety
sciences
who's been invited he's still in he was
a senior scientist there for 18 years
he is the author or co-author on all of
the major studies that cec
has produced on vaccine safety and
particularly the studies that show the
vaccine does not cause autism
his name is dr william thompson three
years ago
he came forward and he said
we have been ordered to fake all the
science
of the last decade on autism and any
any setting in fact we were
in the major study which is called the
stefano 2004's the most cited study on
this subject
any on pubmed and he said in that study
we found out that
black boys who get the mmr vaccine had a
363 percent greater
risk of getting an autism diagnosis and
black boys who waited
after 36 months he said
he was ordered to come into a conference
room
with all that data with his four other
co-authors by their cdc paws frank to
stefano
who then ordered them to destroy that
data in front of them
in cdc headquarters and then published
that study saying
there is no effect and
senior scientists from the cdc so
he's on record is coming out you know
and then there was another scientist
that hooked up with him i think it was
dr hooker and and the whole
documentary mainly revolves around that
where you had this chief scientist who
was
the one who conducted the major
peer-reviewed studies
coming out and saying that you know they
they manipulated the data
you know they lied and there was
actually a 360 percent greater risk of
autism in
african americans right so where do we
go from there and then you had his
boss they he talks about frank uh
destafol his boss in the cdc
coming calling him and the other
co-authors of the study i think the main
study is uh
that people quoted 72 14. you know this
study
so this is one of the main studies that
is quoted uh
saying that there's no link between uh
uh autism and and the vaccine so just to
make it short now so now we see this
this
complete fraud happening right before
our eyes where does the confidence go
confidence go i mean doesn't our dean
teach us like you know
uh how do you know
but you get the point that what he's
bringing up like i said i've seen facts
i've seen the arguments i know a number
of these
uh uh uh scientists i've had
conversations with some of them
seriously different so does that deserve
skepticism does that deserve it
let me tell you about the concept of
skepticism yeah all right
skepticism is an aspect and a tool
of the muslim yeah it's not the muslim
skepticism is an aspect that we use in
islam
to develop narratives to develop truth
to develop an evidence tri uh uh trail
to ensure that our methodology reaches
an objective which is that which is
requested by allah yes
the problem that we have today in
society is that people
turn skepticism into the entire cake
and when muslims think that you know i
can be a muslim skeptic or islamic
skepticism where the skepticism itself
becomes the religion itself
where everything is to be criticized
every single thing is to be considered
to be suspicious they're gonna they're
in for a big shock
our religion you have to be balanced our
religion does not
operate on these principles you will
always find
again as i said you want to bring this
back down to islamic principles
when it comes to our islamic sciences in
any of the areas we'll just take for
example hadith
for example you will always find eminent
authorities that will go against the
wider narrative
eminent we're not talking kennedy's and
10 pennies with my greater respect to
them
who are very minor in the wider scheme
of things yeah i'm talking
imam daruk nis for example that would be
in modern times
if we were let me to give you an example
if we were looking at the area of
vaccines
it would be america pulling out
it would be the world saying they're all
good and america's saying
they're not good that that level not
even going to an individual level it
will be a huge
upset to the system there would be huge
controversy that still does not
as we know very well as muslims
denied the consensus of the alternative
opinion even if as someone as
mighty and powerful and financially
stable as america were to have a
different opinion
for example on israel for example on
israel
america is the only country that
consistently vetoes
every single resolution against israel
does that deny the the consensus of the
international community eddie
does it no no and despite the size of
america
the importance of america the power of
america the western interests and
not interests of america looking at that
meaning
10 000 1000 these figures
in methodology do not compare to tens of
millions
hundreds of millions it is important for
us to understand
that there is no way that we can account
or explain
and neither should we want to try to
refute or assassinate or rubbish
if you're looking at if i was a pro
boxer right
it would be absurdity and and it would
be my downfall
if i was to try to go after dr 10 penny
go after dr radford
go after that study that go after the
filmmakers of vax that have got many
problems
x y z try to uh somehow
repulsively try to uh denigrate
the claim of a mother that her child
died because of xyz
neither is that acceptable neither is it
islamically required
there will always be voices and that are
against and that will claim
evidences our arguments must be based
upon the evidences not on the
personalities
not upon the reality but upon the
numbers look on the consensus
okay there is absolute consensus okay
but there is robert a huge body of
science
that doesn't support your position show
it to me okay well
show it to me i i can but i'm not going
to do that right here tell me one
society
i'll show you a lot of discussion right
now i don't know listen i just want to
know
that children are healthier than
vaccinated children and
i will put that study on my website and
i will quit my job
when it comes to the uh the
authentication
or the regulation of medicines it is the
international community as a whole
and the scientists as a whole that are
looked at not the corrupt practices of
xyz that are found to be guilty in a
court case
or found to have been uh playing with
the figures or trying to avoid
um a scandal cover-up whatever we know
very well that every field has that
whether it's the cigarette field whether
it's tobacco whether it's
oil whether it's water quality whether
it's vaccines
pfizer for example has got lots of game
in this yeah our
our our our uh approach to it as muslims
has to be based upon methodology and not
individual
circumstances not individual actors when
it comes to the actual
uh uh uh sharp end we're looking at the
figures on the ground the people who are
sick the people who are ill the people
who are recovered the people who are
fixed
the people who are in hospital people
out of hospital these are this is the
hard data
there's no doubt we can criticize how we
got to the process
where we start to apply a a a a a
solution or a vaccine protocol or a
strategy
absolutely no doubt and i've spoken
about that at length and i've condemned
that
the problems that that they've been part
of but we look at the reality on the
ground
and the reality on the ground does not
support even better even the only one
of the claims that are being made by the
people against the authorities
against the science against the field
against the individuals involved
against all the healthcare workers
against their reality in our hospitals
against the families that have lost all
their people
it just doesn't and to deny this is
very problematic islamically because
once you start to deny this concept of
torato
of unanimity in opinion of the lack of
possibility of feasible lies
the lack of possibility of everyone
colluding together to create some great
conspiracy once you start to go against
human reality against like that that's
when your deen starts to suffer i don't
mind people suffering in their secular
and setting or back singer couldn't care
less
but if you carry on with this nonsense
your dean will suffer
so let me if i'm understanding correctly
so i'm not misquoting you so the the
thing now that
when i asked this question in our heart
to heart
and me just playing the skeptic and
trying to understand things and relaying
what one side to get to the bottom of
things so now what we're saying when i
ask the question
is that there's a consensus if i'm
understanding of scholarship academics
here
so that trumps what anyone else is going
to say without a
shadow of is that what you're saying
without a shadow of
a doubt show it to me okay well show it
to me i
i can but i'm not going to do that right
here help me understand it
i'll show you a lot of discussion on
right now listen i just want to know
that children are healthier than
unvaccinated children
and i will put that study on my website
and i will quit my job
yeah ah is it a
book is it authentic book yes
here's the key did their leadership as a
imma did their leadership deny
the consensus and the absolute
fact that it is the most authentic book
and it only has authentic hadith no it
didn't
and that is an insight into islamic
methodology exam methodology when it
comes to sources when it comes to
evidence
is not what you may think that every
person who has a point to say
is not given air time every statement
that is made by an authority
is not considered it is the evidence
which is considered
the high realm of probability is what
our religion is based upon
we do not have to have 100
of all people in history agreeing on a
point
to be correct we don't need to be
anywhere near 100
not even close to and that's the
difference as i said
between people who are growing up in a
you know online
everybody got a mouthpiece everybody can
say what they want
and you know creating this kind of
system where when they have a problem
with something
they start to deny the area denied the
field and i want you to
on your viewers to understand this that
we've had this parallel in our history
the groups in our deen like the more
tesla
the those who reject the sunnah in its
entirety
that was their response when they come
across
a anti-vaxx report or a criminal
uh uh uh expose or pfizer for example or
whatever
deny the whole field right off the
entire sign so you can't throw the bait
you're saying you can't throw the baby
out with the bathwater it is
this is not an islamic principle oh no
yes it's not there okay so
this is what i'm gonna go convey back so
i'm gonna you're giving me something
okay to work with
but now if someone comes back again
playing the skeptic and we see at one
time there was a consensus that for
instance you know
uh because certain things develop
science develops and whatnot
so this is a good thing so if we see
certain things because the other side
will argue that look um you will see
uh when they went in front of congress
you had a certain amount of vaccines
they were giving uh before
let's say the 1980s right there was a
handful
and you saw people say there's this huge
body of science
what the science consists of is a
handful a tiny handful
of epidemiological studies that were
written by industry
and by the cdc which is part of the
industry
and none of those studies do all of them
are fatally flawed and i can go through
each one with you
none of those studies do what you would
want a study
that you wanted to excavate vaccines to
actually do
which is to compare a vaccinated
population to an unvaccinated population
and
then look at health outcomes that there
was a limited amount of chronic diseases
right then you know this obviously that
then they went in front of congress
so supreme court actually issued the
statement that
vaccines are unavoidably safe i believe
one in 300
from the dpt vaccine were suffering
brain damage and then
they were getting sued so much and then
from there
they were classified the supreme court
said vaccines are unavoidably unsafe
and there shall be no more lawsuits
against
any vaccine company so legally they're
classified as unavoidably unsafe that's
their legal classification and when i
say that in court in these state
you know cases that i have which are not
injury obviously that's that
that's federal court the judges always
stop me and go
what what did you say wait repeat that
repeat that and i'm like
they're legally classified as
unavoidably unsafe your honor and then
they're like
whoa wait a minute they got to shield
the liability
they said wait a minute we can't sue
them
i mean even those that i have met that
are pro-vaccine
when you let them know that the vaccine
makers cannot
be sued even they say wait a minute i'm
against what you're here for
but i ain't for that you telling me
that i can't sue the vaccine makers if
it's proven that vaccine injured my job
i said no that's right they're
indemnified you can't touch
them and then you have the various
vaccine compensation
fund to this day it's like 4.5 4.6 bill
billion dollars has been paid out the
vaccine courts have paid out
four billion dollars and the threshold
for getting back
into a vaccine court and getting a
judgment
hhs admits that fewer than one percent
of people
who are injured ever even get to court
and then so this is the other side
arguing that look if you're saying
they're safe and effective safe and
effective
doctors in medical school they don't
learn about because they're already
being taught vaccines are safe and
effective
and they're the best thing you can do to
further the health of the population
they're already being taught this and i
was never taught when i was in medical
school 30 years ago
what was in a vaccine we were only
taught that they're wonderful
and do them so no most
doctors trained today have no idea
what's in the vaccines this is
we need to get back to doing that if
we're doing something to a healthy
person
you know you've got a healthy child in
front of you and you're saying well
we're gonna do this thing to you this
vaccine and it's
a good idea and all they're being told
is it's safe and effective
do it and oh by the way if you don't do
it you're gonna have to leave my
practice
that's what's happening today it's that
should be illegal
i mean if if you have a doctor that's
telling you to leave your practice if
you don't do what i say
that's called paternalism and we were
taught in medical school that is the
worst way to practice medicine
yet the academy of pediatrics is now
saying that's okay today pediatricians
are being trained on how to
um i would just use the word coerce
their patients into doing all the
vaccines this is an aside by the way
what you're talking about is fact
so don't you think that this is a sign
this is not a side
anyone who's got half a brain should
know this is absolute fact what you're
talking about okay
let me summarize i'm not making this
stuff up now including giving
eight to ten vaccines on one day so
that is something the institute of
medicine has acknowledged the federal
government disagrees
but i think everybody needs to
understand that child vaccine schedule
has not
been adequately studied for safety fewer
than 40 studies
have actually studied the schedule
that's not enough studies to prove that
that schedule is safe
or effective plus plus there hasn't been
any
um there haven't been any studies at
looking at the synergistic effects of
the ingredients
so if you have one metal
what does it do to the body if you have
one metal and another metal
what does that do to the body if you
have one metal one metal
and antibiotics what does that do to the
body
and it's already been shown that metal
detoxification in the presence of
antibiotics is diminished
versus metal detoxification without
antibiotics
the studies in this book miller's review
of critical vaccine studies this
this book there's 400 studies in here
and these are studies most of these
studies are recent studies
these are all studies that are showing
problems with vaccines
because i got tired of hearing
medical doctors saying there are no
studies
that show that vaccines are a problem
that vaccines are unsafe what are you
talking about that is an
outright lie there are hundreds if not
thousands of studies it published in
peer-reviewed journals
documenting safety and efficacy
problems associated with vaccines
correct
okay the early vaccines had major
problems
they had side effects they were using
certain like you gave the example in the
beginning of you know
wanting to take mercury out of fish
doesn't mean that you're against fish
actually it was those original people
who kind of like stood up
and i made this point in the lecture
before if they hadn't
right today mercury possibly uh allah
knows best of course
but today you would have found in the
covered vaccine for example
mercury right it's very very power or
ethanol mercury
in in one of its forms uh or a few years
ago
there has to be people that question and
and
argue and so on and so forth so facts
are facts as for the vaccine uh uh
um uh uh payout injury payment
scheme in 1988 it is very important that
we understand that you can make that
fact reality and we have one in the uk
as well
um which is also paid out huge millions
okay
you can make that either work for you
or work against you just like numbers so
you're either
going to if you believe in the concept
of medicines
and you understand the urgency and this
is from a
pro healthcare point of view if you
believe in the
the efficacy of vaccines or medicine in
principle safe and
tested ones i'm not talking about
anything controversial
and you believe that the nature and the
reality
of the litigation culture that we live
in i mean u.s
obviously leads that right and it's now
made a major impact on the rest of the
world
where people are very very afraid and
scared to do certain things because of
fear of
litigation and you see that that
actually has
a marked impact upon performance
safety and so on i'll give you an
example of safety right
just to break it down to the to the
viewer as
a pharmacist or as a doctor if i make a
prescribing mistake so i see
it saying i'm a trypto lean and i give
out amlodipine right so it's a drug
which is meant to send you to sleep or
to give you for anxiety
and he said i give a drug for blood high
blood pressure that's a pretty
i want to say i don't say safe but i
mean you're not going to most cases
you're not going to die but it's a
serious
error right same strength same whatever
what not and i now give that to you
most of the time some in the family
spots it has a look at this and says you
know this is not what i was told by
doctor and they
read it or they don't spot it they have
the complete trust in the pharmacist
and they take it and they start feeling
really bad they take the box into the
doctor
doctor says i never brought you that
blah blah blah blah so this happens
in all fields in all areas and what do
the regulatory bodies do
how do you think that they they deal
with that they
uh uh uh introduce systems that are
error reporting
error reporting systems are meant to be
that let's try to identify a pattern of
how these mistakes actually
occur right and see if we can find
tiredness or if we can find where
there's a mental blackout if you're
standing in a certain position
and whether you should take a mental
break each time that you check a
prescription it's like the only way that
you can
make those rulings or those decisions is
to get data
the only way that you can get data is
how for people to be what
honest enough to go and say i made a
mistake
no no no one likes to say i made a
mistake and sometimes if you make a big
mistake
you're going to be you know it's a
difficult place to be
and so what was happening it was a
complete failure it was a complete
failure
because nobody was willing to report we
have to understand that you know these
ideas that people come up with in their
conspiracy theories
and it genuinely is they don't work in
real life
the idea that you can somehow just
assume that the world is going to be
okay because people are going to be
honest and just fair with one another
that they're not going to
go for litigation that they're not going
to you know hang someone out to drive to
make a mistake they're not going to
you're not going to look to whether a
person is sincere or not sincere the
person did it on purpose or not whether
there was corruption or not but we're
just going to hang them out to try or
i can make a living out of this or i can
make money i can pay my house off with
this
there are people out there that do that
that's the real world and
if you take this view then you see that
the injury payment scheme
that allows genuine in obviously what we
hope
genuine attempts to try to create
medicine that's trying to help
that not trying to cause problems and
that there is a risk and all of them
will say there's a risk
and if there is a risk at least we can
minimize the
the impact upon the rest of the good
that's being done
right by mitigating that risk and taking
it off their hands
governments jumped at that chance
because they saw greater benefits
than a cost and risk even 4.5 billion
which is peanuts
to how much it would cost them if a
pandemic went out of control
for example just using 4.5 billion as a
a year cost today
if the if the american government had
the chance to pay 4.5
trillion forget about 4.5 billion to
avoid the impact of one year
donald trump would have paid 405
trillion to have paid
you know uh to avoid covet and him
losing his his spot
let alone the impact upon the rest of
people and their lives obviously he
couldn't care less about that but any
country
so everything is based upon benefit
benefit and risk and if you look at that
as
somehow the the the government is
actually a wider extension of the
pharmaceutical company
and they're doing that to for the
fraudulent interests
of the of the pharmaceutical which i can
accept is a theory
right that's the reason they're doing it
so they can make sure they make their
profits
well once you've gone down that line
actually the game's over would you smile
to go and find yourself yeah coffin and
jump in and die
because once you've now said that the
government is now the pharmaceutical
companies
and the pharmaceutical companies is the
government and they're all just trying
to rank you for money
and they're trying to make you die and
make sure that you don't have to you
can't claim enough money
and everybody is now protected that
there's one massive conspiracy theory to
life and existence
in in this fundamental sense once that
conclusion has been reached then what's
the point of life then
there's no hope for us what the argument
that's being made is and if i understand
your second
second uh point here as is that um let
me just uh kind of i have a
i don't wanna i wanna limit this to uh
we're almost out of time and
but i have a i wanna get your action uh
answer to some of these questions that
we also have that are
uh here uh if you can like uh
give me some of a semi you know
condensed version of it or directly
so so back to the back point before we
went on so if you have for instance
these inserts right which uh it's
doctors don't learn about vaccines in
medical school
right they don't learn they learn about
the schedule they learn about they don't
learn about the ingredients they don't
learn about these things so but they
learn something far more valuable they
learn the principle of how to deal with
evidence
they understand the concept of
peer-reviewed journals of understanding
authorities
of understanding the key points of data
points that matter
nobody is expected to learn let alone
and i'm no favor i'm not a massive
friend of the doctors right okay but
just
you know being a failed doctor myself
i'm the sworn enemy okay
so as a pharmacist we hate doctors but
let's just make it clear
doctors are not expected not as
pharmacists as any professional
in any field to know absolutely
everything about everything when they're
studying
they're meant to learn principles that
equip them to deal with every single new
release new medicine
on its own merits with its own details
so for for people to claim
that because you're a professor in
immunology or you are an epidemiologist
for example that the doctors themselves
will not be able to understand this
is patently untrue yeah patently false
yeah so the point what they make is that
uh
they themselves these doctors who are
also you know
giving out the shots they didn't learn
anything but then when they learned
about
you know the mercury is that most
doctors in america haven't actually
taken the time to do the fundamental
research that they need to do
to figure out what the true risks and
benefits are
of any given vaccine so in this country
we don't really have
informed consent when it comes to
vaccines and i think we've
lost our way in looking at vaccines
and looking at what are the iatrogenic
effects in other words what harm
is being done by our vaccine program
so you know i wrote this book the
vaccine friendly plan because
because just to be to so people know
you're not anti-vaccine
absolutely not so the dilemma i was in
in 2008 after i had those four cases of
uh children who regressed into severe
autism and i'd already learned about
toxicity i'd read studies on thimerosal
on aluminum toxicity i mean there's
books on this topic
it just i could no longer ethically
keep doing vaccines business as usual
with the cdc schedule
and the things that concerned me the
most were that hepatitis b dose for
newborns
back then they weren't pushing vaccines
on pregnant women that's happened since
and the sheer number of vaccines that
were being given for example at the
two-month visit we were giving
six different vaccines three of which
had too much aluminum
so you're multiplying huge toxins adding
on top adding on top
and it was just clearly not
a scientifically justifiable approach
when you understand toxicity the
aluminum formaldehyde all these toxic
chemicals then they learned about you
know that there is no true double-blind
placebo the gold standard for vaccines
i'm the institute of medicine which is
the national academy of science which is
the ultimate arbiter
of vaccine safety science has repeatedly
said to cdc
you are claiming that you have studied
this issue particularly the issue
between autism and vaccines
you have not oh it's not robert kennedy
it's the institute of medicine which is
the highest
scientific authority in our government
right has repeatedly said
to cdc you have not done the studies
necessary to make these claims that you
are making in 20
they learned that there is no true
safety what does that even mean there's
no true double blind study what does
that even mean
there's no that's the goal what they say
is that's the gold standard
it is the gold standard for safety for
because of the shield of liability
there's no incentive so for example let
me see layman's terms if you're trying
to buy a car and you know that you
cannot sue the manufacturer
and then the manufacturer has been sued
and sued over for all the deficiencies
in their car would you buy the car so
now people are scared
now they have vaccine injury children
and now
they're getting these uh these doctors
that's a criticism against the company
when it comes to taking a vaccine how is
that criticism against the
the trial uh which trial the i'm saying
that the example that you gave
yeah that would be a good example of how
we should be critical against the
company
itself when it comes to their product
yes okay how is that a problem against
double uh blind uh
placebo uh so yeah so the
contention that people have is that now
because of the shield of liability they
don't have an incentive nor do they do a
double-blind placebo
for these mmr and all these other
vaccines there's no double-blind placebo
so that's
they're i think vaccines have have
saved millions of lives and i just
accepted the dogma that they were safe
and and that that's what the science
said i started looking at the science
and i started calling people
within the agencies i called paul offit
who was a big defender of vaccines and i
call it
old uh kathleen stratton at cdc and
other people within the agencies and i
started questioning them
and uh their answers
they gave me the answers that they gave
to the public but i was informed about
the science and when i started drilling
down with them on the science it was
clear that
not only that the science they were
citing me
was bogus but that
they knew that it was weak and they were
unwilling to defend it
in front of informed criticism
and that shocked me because these were
not i was used to
environmental agencies becoming captured
but
a public health agency that is charged
with protecting the health of our
children
to lie about science um and to
manipulate
science which is what they were doing uh
that just seemed criminal trying to get
them they're trying to get them
there and they're also trying to get the
robert f kennedy he also makes his point
why don't they open up the records what
what they mean is every doctor that goes
he documents injuries that are happening
uh to children
which are vaccinated which are not if
they would just open
up the the records we would we would end
this debate they don't they're not doing
that
uh we're not doing that yeah and in in
the uk there is no secret records
the yellow we have a yellow triangle uh
every country has its own
uh adverse effect reporting system okay
you've seen a lot of you know debate you
know one of the most hilarious ones was
the 3916
vaccine related injuries that were
reported in december okay
and you've got people who have
absolutely not a single clue about
neither vaccines or adverse effects
or injuries through their little videos
going around
saying that 3916 events
and you think this vaccine is safe okay
well first of all
you either have to accept this this
eddie
is what blows my mind all right for a
muslim to claim this
first of all i would say to such a
person
are you happy to stick with hundred and
sixteen uh
like uh do you want to put this forward
as a valid point
what's there for 319 what is that yeah
it's it's it's the
it's the latest you know salvo in this
battle that
how can we you know the 23 doctors 23
people in norwegian and norway died as a
result of this
the the baseball player whatever his
name hank bloody blah whatever you want
the american guy
who died after taking the vaccine yeah
blah blah blah so this is all part of
the crescendo that
hold on how is this even safe how's it
even safe when we have these people
dying
yeah so you can admit that these are
ones and twos and tens and twenties yeah
but i'll say no don't worry
take your 3916 okay
right and i'll give you that which is
very different to one or two people
3916 if i gave you that 4 000 people as
i say
i have had these effects when people
push it forward they think that the rest
of the world is stupid that as if
4 000 people have died as a result of
taking the vaccine
that the concept of adverse effect which
is sometimes an upset stomach by the way
sometimes a fever which has gone on for
longer than two days
or three days that gets noted down as an
adverse effect
there are tears for what happens
now that's just one fact what about
what what about what about the epilepsy
so let me let me just
make your point that you're about to put
ahead unless i will give you
even that 3960 people died
i'll even say that for you eddie okay
which didn't
not even 300 people died not even 30
people died let alone 3 000
but i would say say 4 000 people died
islamically forget about not every other
system because this is the dean show
right brother
four thousand people died let's have a
look at how many vaccinations have been
given
there's been about four or five million
in the uk there's been about
x million in the states i don't know
i've got no idea
maybe 50 million in the world have done
or 10 million or 20 million
if you start looking at the numbers of
people who are dead as a result of that
i'm just taking a very fatalistic
because it's all false
the 4000 didn't die but i'm just saying
let's assume that it did would we reject
the solution the savior the
that's a horrible word let me protect
that out let's just say a medical
uh aid in trying to combat a pandemic
and we would base its acceptability or
not acceptability
on four thousand let's do it this let's
do the figure
so give me your question give me your
question so when i go back to someone
like sherry tenpenny oh they'll know
this question
they know it very well because they love
figures no point
no not one okay as a
fatality risk all right that means one
in i don't know how many billion
whatever that risk is of a person dying
i don't know whatever whatever it is
i i won in a million one in one in a
hundred i don't know i can tell you that
every act of your daily life is more
risky of you living your life so what's
going on so the question you would your
post going outside and walking to your
car
you have a one in 114 chance of falling
and dying
okay one in 114 and people are going to
say
that the fact that there's a risk out
there that that
three foot three thousand four nine
hundred four thousand people have died
which they haven't but let's just assume
that means that the is off the table
it's a conspiracy
it's proof that the whole system is
broken it's nonsense yeah
listen it's nonsense islamically this is
not
sustainable yeah we're not it's
different from an evidence yeah
going down a dark hole of uh going down
we can't you know i guess
you know just like uh uh there are
things that go on you know you have
conflicts of interest we talked about
that's the i think that's the main thing
it's not like you know okay there's
like people sitting down around just
like i don't think we can be naive to
the fact that
you you don't have you know uh the the
pharmaceutical industry is not really
about eliminating disease they're about
managing symptoms and making profits and
money right so
100 percent they're they're not about
this they're not they're not about
sitting around
these these people let me just finish
these are not people who have taqwa
you know god consciousness and they're
thinking about how how are we going to
save the world lecture right you've seen
my first lecture on this yeah you saw
how it skewered the industry yes
yes okay i only did one bit of
preparation for this interview i spent
five minutes doing some calculations
yeah okay five minutes that's the only
thing i done and i want to just show it
to you
the reason why you know that and i want
to say this to calm the hearts of the
people who are getting angry at what i'm
saying because they are anti
again they are not you know they think
that the curvy has been exaggerated they
think that they
you know their civil liberties are
trashed they don't want to wear masks
they don't want all of this nonsense but
what would you say but you would you say
that people are politicians others i
mean there's some
you know uh uh there's some validity to
like for instance the look look at when
i don't know what your view now is of 9
11 for instance you know
people capitalize on this do you still
think look i
i'm not a conspiracy theorist even
though i think this term you have labels
that are thrown out there
to kind of just make people look dumb
stupid you know and and
and to prevent you know good healthy
talks like we're having you follow me
so but when you look at when you look at
a building number seven go down
and no plane hit it nothing what are you
supposed to say you know i'm not getting
into everything else
so but then i i get it listen but but
let me just finish this
but then you have people then you have i
don't understand it but then
yeah but then you have people pay
passing bills like the patriot act you
follow me
people you know listen
so you do have you do absolutely so you
do have people who are capitalizing off
this for political
okay yes that's what i'm saying we can't
be naive to that look at the
100 but that does that deny
that the presence no the problem no no
that's the problem right that's the the
issue that we have here
that a valid argument is turned into the
entire pie
and that is unacceptable what how it
happened
whether the chinese made it or whether i
made it
or whether it was sent by allah as a
pure punishment
it is actually irrelevant when it comes
to the treating of it
they plan
as muslims it's relevant in our
spiritual response
because if we spend all of our time
thinking
who manufactured it it was bio bio
weapons but we spend our entire time
we're wasting we're going to adjusting
time
let me get let me get some facts let me
get let's stay let me stay from a
punishment from allah
let me stay academic it makes it makes
us yeah let me just change our ways
right yeah so what i'm trying to say is
that there's a spiritual response
and that's important and then there's a
practical one whoever is profiting about
it and we
we know millions of people making
trillions out of it
whoever is abusing the system whoever
whatever it does not change to that my
uncle passed away on monday
it didn't change that uh so-and-so
passed away of it
that your uncle your uncle passed away
he did may allah graham janna
i give that example because it doesn't
change
it doesn't make me more emotional to it
it doesn't make me more pro it doesn't
make me more thinking
why because we go on the evidence before
my uncle was even
ill there were uncles passing away
before these uncles were passing away
and they were not even people who were
getting in
our community our own brothers myself
included and many people
around me were in intensive care units
were in
hospitals that were struggling to deal
with this unknown disease that was
decap decapacitating the health care
system and so on so forth now
now listen this is a very important
point does that make
the pandemic the international
catastrophe that is made out to be
no it doesn't but what do we read it as
we do see it as this catastrophe because
it affects us more in the west
when you have a system because you asked
earlier on that there was a time earlier
on where
vaccines were seen as you know a basic
simple kind of idea and then suddenly it
exploded
and it you know unavoidable injury you
gave the example right oh sorry what did
you say unavoidable
the supreme court the supreme court
issued
that the vaccines are uno they're
unavoidably unsafe and they said to
congress
we cannot make this we cannot make
vaccines safely they are unavoidably
unsafe that
is the phrase in the statute of
unavoidably unsafe unsafe yeah they're
so unavoidable
i want to imagine that as you said that
there was a point
which you can bring to a case a supreme
court in a year
where the attitude towards vaccines like
flipped it was like you know
portion and suddenly it's now part of
life right and it
and this is a reality that we've created
yeah right that us in the west when you
become dependent on a certain
level of life when you expect for every
coffin cold or for every pain
that you're going to be looked after a
by a healthcare professional when you
expect
that an illness is just routine when you
expect to survive a heart attack
the vast majority of people that have
heart attacks survive
the vast people who have stroke survive
a thousand years ago 100 years ago
to 500 years ago the vast majority of
people
died they died we live in a different
world
we've created that system especially in
the western developed world
in america 25.8
intensive care beds for every 100 000
this is the figures i wanted to show you
yeah yeah
25.8 says say 26 beds
for every 100 000 population
intensive care in pakistan
right which is my own country and
nigeria bangladesh the big kind of
countries bangladesh in
indonesia the muslim heavyweights right
okay
all of it is less than one less than one
the numbers are infertilely small if
you're just talking about hospital beds
when it comes intensive care something
else
that just goes to show you when you grow
up in a village in pakistan
it doesn't matter if the whole world is
going through a pandemic or there's a
disease out there that's causing you not
to be able to breathe then you need
pruning and you need
ventilators and a cpap and all the rest
of it because you're going to be left at
home with no chance of going to hospital
anyway
and you're either going to have to deal
with it or just die and the rest of the
village is going to just deal with it
and they're going to pray over you and
they're going to bury you that's it
but when you leave you live in the west
where you've got 25 26 beds where you've
got every possibility of surviving what
you that which you should not survive
you create a mindset when you have a
certain level of food being available at
all times when you want pineapple and
mango
and watermelon in the wrong season
when you want drinks on tap when you
want life to be as it is like we live
you create your own circumstances you
create your own problems
very well known someone like yourself
that over cleanliness and overuse of
antisepsis disinfectants and bleachers
have created their own resistance
to have created these this uh a
rampant disease uh allergies to spread
even further and further and you're
looking at people who live in the
deserts and in the forests
who got absolutely no issues strongest
immunity in the world
not touch their medicine they don't get
taken down by any of this stuff
we create our own problems yeah once the
problems have been created
a disease comes along that exploits that
dependency upon the healthcare system
that exploits that reality the financial
system that we have
the uk for example financially we don't
create much we don't export and import
much ours is a services based industry
services
we have suffered our gdp has collapsed
because of our people not willing to go
out
confidence fear scared blah blah blah
and
their own desires and their wants and
you know that i'm going to be looked
after
and the hospital is going to take care
of me our reaction
is a manufactured artificial reaction
that's created
and exaggerated a reality which is
serious but not that serious
in the world kind of scheme of things
and that is the level of exaggeration
which is
which is acceptable and should be taught
to the people but that does not
that does not support the idea that it's
fake that it's
code that it's a pandemic that is big
that it's xy and that's the problem
people cannot be balanced and discuss
the evidence
as what it is let me get to a few more
questions and i know
a few more questions here since you
mentioned statistic and again this is
one that robert f kennedy brings up
and i'm playing a skeptic here since i
couldn't put you guys together 2010
hhs a federal agency was was
commissioned to look into the cdc claim
that only one
uh one in one million is injured due to
vaccines they found that
it was actually 2.6 percent that mean
one in 40 people were actually getting
seriously
injured i was commissioned to look at
vaccine injury because
edc for many years had been saying
vaccine injury
only occurs one in a million but what
ahrq found with the federal agency they
looked at one hmo
which was a harvard pilgrim hmo and they
did a machine
cluster analysis on in other words
artificial intelligence counting a very
very accurate accounting system
they at the actual rate of vaccine
injury
is 2.6 that means 140 people
get seriously injured by vaccines uh
by these vaccines so the contention is
that they have is that we have a
perfectly healthy human being
and we're going to go ahead to keep
prevent someone from us getting sick
how do we balance that when you have in
a medical intervention
so you want a quick answer this is how
you balance it you balance let me just
let me just finish let me just finish
yeah
so how do we balance when when we back
it up we got unavoidable to be safe
by uh then we have on by the
supreme court then you have this unsafe
then you have in the vaccine inserts you
have that
uh all these 100 200 plus
side effects uh eff encephalitis uh
brain swelling
uh epileptic seizures not just like you
know
eddie eddie let me make it easy for you
i'm a pharmacist right so you know all
this yeah
obviously i'm a pharmacist right so then
we start most of the time if i give
medicines out to a person
but you guys don't want to hear this
because you know it's not sexy enough
for this
have you heard of pharmacists every time
pharmacists have been forced to develop
blood pressure to tablets why not every
time
but i would look at the person and i'll
make a decision on whether i take out
the the patient information leaflet or
not
because reading that is well-known
studies right yeah it destroys a person
it literally whatever you have a
conversation with them you try to inform
them and so
forth all right and you got to make a
call that this person is going to become
actually more ill than the reason
they're taking the flipping tablet for
just for reading this there's brain
surgery this brain
even death even death even death right
i'm going to turn into a flipping copper
or
this that whatever he's having a heart
attack reading this this thing
yeah and you got to realize that the
evidence does not support
that happening in real life at the
percentages that we know
that a pain or a fever or whatever so
listen
when i i vaccinate i vaccinate people
when i vaccinate a person i will tell
them what they're likely to get
and i will tell them that if they get
this next stage level
of symptoms at this stage then
you do this this this
i don't tell anybody that listen there's
a possibility that you could die
i don't and anybody who would say that
every time that you give a medicine
or a pill or you know if i give you a
melon
and i say to you right eat carefully
there's a possibility that you could die
on this
here's a lovely red apple but there is a
one in 300 chance of you choking on this
do you say it every time you give an
apple so when you're giving a medicine
and the chance of dying
is one in even a hundred yes which is
not
it's like one in x million whatever it
is okay whatever it is and
it could change it could god could go
down is that what you say when you give
a person
a medicine of course you don't but
there's informed consent
doctors that's you know you have every
single person
is aware right now of the realities of
the vaccine
yeah i mean if if there is if there's
willing
disinformation if there is you know as i
said before
again in the lectures and never can any
person say that these are 100 safe
never can we say that there is
absolutely free of long-term side
effects
absolutely possible people are that's
why in our country
in the uk a product license for pfizer
it has very clearly stated
we've not tested this in pregnant women
have a conversation with pregnant women
and make them aware of what the reality
is
fertility we have absolutely no data
that we could you know there's
they haven't got a chance that the fisa
is you know got that that much guts even
though
it's protected right protected against
being sued
and yet they still haven't got the guts
to say
uh uh if you want fertility is not a
problem
because there's things bigger than just
being sued
can you imagine can you imagine if they
were stupid enough
to based upon the limited studies which
we all know clinical trials were only 40
000 by the way
good number not enough though to please
everybody
but if i now turn around and say okay
then are you muslims happy to take the
800 000 cohort study from israel then
you'd be turning around and say oh but
the israelis and they're just dead
that's the problem you can't please
everybody all the time there are figures
that can be manipulated that can be
looked at you can start to see certain
subgroups
at the moment when you're seeing the
problems with the figures is because
certain subgroups amongst the the trial
participants are focused on so out 22
000 people
that are chosen to receive the vaccine
and the other received the placebo when
you're starting to look at
for example minority ethnic groups it's
only a couple of hundred for example
amongst that 23 000. and if you're
looking at pregnant women it was never
intentionally tested on pregnant women
but some women
became pregnant during the trial do we
now use this data
to say that you're safe in pregnant
women can you imagine how stupid that
would be how do we answer the question
like when we're
where after this seal the liability the
vaccine schedule went from a few
to like 72 plus uh doses and then they
have
the answer is that was an incredibly
successful policy by the government
that's the reason they brought it in
no way they wanted their increased value
here's what they're saying
professionals do i'm playing the
skeptics so here's what they're saying
is that after that we saw chronic health
issues like never before like you had
i agree with that as well so then you
have one in ten thousand once
you've entered into that once you've
opened that door good luck in closing it
i
completely agree with you so we went
away we have wishes i could hunt my own
food like you do
and wishes i could be as fit as you i
know
what it's like to want to be able to
live that healthy life away from all
medicines away from all artificial stuff
everything organic pay the big monies
and get everything pure
once you i like when the door to eating
chicken
uh scissors i like what you said there
you said that before you said if you're
somebody who's uh drinking coca-cola
eating all this garbage and now you know
what's in the
you know what i'm trying to say it's
true though isn't it but here's the
thing that people
uh they're scared of because they're and
and you agree that you shouldn't if you
don't want to take
these drugs you shouldn't be forced to
but here's the here's the problem the
other side is worried about and why
they're
uh speaking out is because they're gonna
soon they're saying they're eliminating
your right right you're they're not
eliminating any rights
listen the idea that we choose no this
is happening
like in california in california no in
california
like california here in places you keep
it in the uk
uh a cruise company went on record last
week and said that no one is allowed to
go into a cruise company that's not had
the vaccine
okay if the government decide to do that
the government decides to do that guess
what you're not going to cruise with
that company end the story bro
if you don't want to take the vaccine
because you are so scared
about the meningitis ac w y vaccine and
its impact upon you
and you are not going to go and do
performance then good luck to you
that's your own decision yeah that's
something which you as a personal person
will have to question
we'll have to answer for in front of
allah it's not obligatory to take
medications
and back what about what about this what
about this so we if that's your choice
but there's a big difference between you
saying
i don't know about any problems i'm not
sure but all i know is that
i don't want to take it or i am positive
that this is going to cause me a problem
i'm
very careful about my food i make sure
that i eat i don't i avoid this i avoid
it i avoid
that why the fish would i get involved
with you know some manufactured vaccine
i respect you more power to you don't
say to other people that
it's a corrupt industry it's all over
everyone's in haram it's all made of
fetuses
it's going to kill you that's lies lies
lies lies lies lies
lies so there's a big difference between
a person
in full consent looking at the evidences
and seeing what the overall ruling is
yes some people might die yes some
people might come across an
impure vaccine hpv vaccine which i gave
a lecture about
i said any muslim that is getting
involved with the hpv vaccine
has a bigger problem than the hpv itself
right you understand what hpv is right
the the hepatitis y i think
when there is that whole kind of you
know young
men and women are doing you know sexual
partners oh let me that's another conte
why why are they giving
that's one of the questions here i i i
answer the us
watch watch the islam 21c podcast like i
said the u.s vaccinates newborn babies
with
hvhp vaccines which are originally
designed for prostitutes and druggies
why are they
why are they injecting newborn babies
that i just gave on that yeah i just
said to you
if a person is thinking about giving
his or her daughter or family you know
the hpv vaccine
preventative meaning before it happens
yeah all right you've got a bigger
problem than the hpv vaccine
what on earth is happening to a terabia
and i will bring up our families
if we feel that as a country we need to
immunize
our muslim population against hpv so
you're against that vaccine of course i
am okay so you're okay
i mean like i thought you think you saw
the lectures wasted my time man
okay no but they didn't see it i want
you to i don't want to say it i want you
to under so you're saying
okay what point all right here's the let
me just get watching all right here's
here here come the questions people are
asking watching i shout normally
eddie doesn't but eddie is an mma guy so
when he sees the other guy and he come
on yanni you know
i smash this boy then he gets old he
loves that behavior
he's very happy today because his his
other boy
got smashed by dustin pouring the
diamond smashed hardcore
so eddie's happy i'm happy but my point
is is everyone who's watching this
we love each other the actual yes
yesterdays are important
my lectures are on this you will realize
that i'm not pro-vaccine
that i'm not pro-medicines i just
believe pro-evidence i believe that
vaccines are safe on the whole i believe
and trust the
regulatory agencies in general i know
that there's corruption i know that
there's problems i know that there are
uh uh deficiencies in every area
testing pcr testing right we know that
they are super sensitive producing so
much results that you can't depend upon
the results that the the the source it
is the irony that's a fact what i just
said you agree with that don't you okay
i agree with that here's the irony the
source
and the authorities that gave us that
information
that people suddenly ignore them when
they say but we should still continue
with pcr testing
so it's like ah pcr tests it's all false
it's all rubbish
who told you that oh the british medical
journal oh the lancer all right let's go
and ask them what do they say about
using it they say well you should use it
okay let's ask them what they think
about the vaccine
yes we encourage all people to take the
vaccine we're ignoring that part
but you're focusing on the pcr testing
being unreliable
etc you know what i'm trying to say if
this is a this is a discussion that
needs to be
brought back down to how we deal with
evidences and that's the reason why
muslims
muslims are failing in this eddie and
this is where i want to start bringing
it to a close and i want you to come in
with your
quick quick questions yeah let me get
those questions yeah our bigger problem
is that the muslims have forgotten how
to deal with evidence we are people of
evidence
we have for our our entire history dealt
with evidence that suggests one thing
and then a consensus which it suggests
something else
and then difference of opinion which is
50 50 and you know
specific positions from specialists
versus generalists traditionalists
versus contemporaries
et cetera et cetera et cetera et cetera
our dean teaches us
key principles and methodology and how
to deal with all of this it's because
muslims are so far away from their
religion
that they are unable to deal with data
not able to sift through statistics
statistics statistics they're not able
to understand who are authorities
and once they go back and apply basic
islamic principles they realize just how
untenable the movement which is whether
you call it in a pejorative term
anti-advances or whatever you want to
call them those people who are denying
this or
or reducing that or trying to create
conspiracy theories whatever you'll
realize
why that's completely untenable from a
practicing
solid sunni muslim go ahead here are the
questions what would poison control
tell you if a parent fed their child
some of these toxic ingredients
every two months like they inject in dpt
and other vaccines
it will be completely unacceptable and
haram if the evidence supported it the
evidence in our current vaccination
schedule does not support that
explain the difference between ingestion
and injection
uh in terms of ingestion islamically or
or just
the question here is like you know when
you go through like aluminum let's say
it goes through
your mouth and some food and the idea
that people will say
no problem being injected with aluminum
because we eat yeah aluminium
uh injection injection versus digestion
correct there is absolutely no doubt
that's the whole going through god's
system so you have god's system on
elimination but now you when you inject
no eddie don't go down that line but you
know what i'm saying you know allah put
the kidneys
allah put the system eddie be careful
don't bring god into it i'll tell you
why because that would suggest that
allah has forbidden injections which of
course
he hasn't no no i'm not saying no no no
yeah so that's my point
what they're arguing they're arguing
there's no such thing as god's system
this is god's system everything yes god
yes
god system is not just through here
right so i know i know how you went
there
you got a bit excited that's okay but
the point is is that
all of it's system but your primary
argument is good uh
we should not be testing and that's why
it is a weak argument it's not a very
strong argument and i know i
put my hand up i've made that point
before that from your dietary ingestion
of aluminium
aluminium aluminum we say aluminium by
the way right
aluminum that it is not comparable to
direct
instant bloodstream straight possibly
going to the brain
there's no there's no there is no there
is no actual comparison they're two
different
uh routes so what should be the
comparison
is the data the data that shows the
the after effects the side effects the
poisoning of
that level of aluminum going to the
brain
via injection and the data does not
support that it is as simple as that
do you know do you know about the
toxicologists uh they've done extensive
work
chris axley and ashley everly uh the
fact that alzheimer's patients and
autistic
patients both have one thing in common
aluminum
in their gut and brains and you can see
their their studies now do you know
about this
you don't have to come if you don't i i
know about this and you know what the
great thing about this particular study
is that you don't even need to know a
single thing about
aluminum or about science or about
anything to know
that algerian and alzheimer's and
senility and the increase of this
a problem is occurring in communities
that don't even have
access to aluminum let alone adjuvants
let alone injections let alone anything
of that
so that's got to be said now back to the
previous point
that once we opened the door to diet
coke bro okay
you should expect absolutely everything
to go wrong with humans
human beings i i'm very serious i know
people find that funny and i even i make
jokes of it
but it's true the modern world right
i i actually support what these folks
are saying right
and i really you know i'm a massive joe
rogan fan for example right
he's something that i'm sure that you
listen to because obviously you know
you've got your you're the halal version
did you see him once
wearing a red civic t-shirt i don't know
i have i have my
he's got pros and cons right so you know
you know you know what kind of things
that he does which are disgusting and
haram and all the rest of it
doesn't mean we throw away the good
stuff right okay and my point is is that
our islam teaches us that it's good to
be taken back to be taken if you've got
a person you know
there's a lot of the american culture
that i've learned from him
because he's obviously a wealthy man
he's got access to doing certain things
in his way of life
that way that other people can only
dream about living off the land living
off the grid living x living white blah
blah blah
my point is this that once you open that
door to unhealthy living or to eat like
the masses do and the public whatever
i have no doubt whatsoever that we're
all gonna [ __ ] i think i'm suffering
from outsiders now bro
and i'll blame this damn flipping diet
coke right here okay
i'm addicted to this stuff that's why i
couldn't care less what's in a vaccine
i'm going to be straight out to you bro
if you want me to give the emotional
argument delay people argument that's
the reality
once you open up a diet coke the most
horrible disgusting
infected yeah anything in human history
right
and yeah i am expected to worry about
what's in it so if you stay away from
coke then stay away from vaccines that's
what you're saying absolutely
i told you even that's a very high bar
here's the next question
uh we're almost done i've got a gift for
you have you seen this
that's a vile what the what is that it
is indeed bro that's for you man that's
for you
only to put it up and to put it on your
your dart board do you guys know you
have darts
you know what darts yes yes yes so you
can put it there and you can just crack
the crap what what's that one is that
the v
is that the uh bioentec yeah yeah
empty by the way otherwise it'll be
worth a couple hundred pounds yeah and
illegal as well
in pharmacy school they learned that
there are toxic chemicals
that they need protective gear to handle
so the question is why is it
then that these toxic chemicals are okay
to put in vaccines
into chinese babies uningest next
question
okay why is it that u.s has the highest
number of vaccinated kids and yet has
the highest number of infant deaths
yeah that is bro this is it
now that's a quality question right
that's a quality question with answers
that go
way beyond the scope of this program
we should be asking ourselves when we
look at
the death that deaths that is being
compared to in another country
for example how is the reporting of
those deaths
being uh uh occurring in said country
like for example pakistan
if we were to take any a city and say a
hundred thousand and we see
the amount of kids that have died right
what's the reporting like
how is the actual figures comparing to
amer
you know the ones that are american
american-based you see
here's the problem americans have
created their own
problem like actually you know everybody
hates donald trump but the guy come up
with some
pretty quality statements a very very
true ones
and everyone ridiculed it for everyone
everyone ridiculed him for it
like last year when he was saying that
the reason that we have the greatest
number of infections is because
what did he say trump yeah
the reason why i forgot what he say
because we do the most
tests okay because we're doing the most
testing yeah i see what you're saying
right
so that's true people were ridiculing
him for
it but it's true if you have a system
yeah
do you honestly think that in pakistan
and in x and y and in all these other
countries
which i speak to regularly and they're
like what corona what are you talking
about
you know do you honestly think that
they've got no infection there do you
honestly think that there is nothing
there but people don't care about it
people don't test for it people can't
afford to test for it
people don't have the time to test for
it people don't care for the testing
so when it comes to numbers and figures
there's far more questions that need to
be asked as well so
when you say the highest number first of
all i wouldn't accept that i don't want
to rubbish this data i
i find this particular area fascinating
i want to know though
is that how are we measuring that
against other countries in infant water
where infant mortality is of higher
numbers but the classification for the
cause of death
and registration of death is in question
just like for example
the number of people who die so in
america there'll be
multi thousand every day at the moment
okay that are dying out of covet
you know and i know that the system that
that designates a person to have died of
covet is
full of problems right in the uk it is
any death that occurs within a 28-day
period of someone returning a positive
clover test
you know that right go ahead your miles
away aren't you you're absolute miles
away no no
the person's eyes are just miles away
it's okay eddie back with me now
yeah back with me here that is a problem
if you're saying that a death rate
a a death is being ascertained as
coveted
because he died within 28 days of a
covert test yeah you can understand that
that's a problem
at the same time what's the alternative
what's the alternative
you can either go full the other side
and say well
let's not do any testing whatsoever and
just write it off as overall deaths and
some countries are doing that right so
they look
don't they don't look at covert deaths
they compared the previous year's death
rate for that month
they look at this year's at this month
this year
and the discrepancy they're putting that
down to and they they make an estimate
the algorithm makes an estimate of
an increase in car accidents and
increasing domestic abuse and then they
look and then the rest
the difference they're saying that's
covered so that's the second approach
you can see the problem
with that as well then you've got the
other approach which is
no every person who dies upon death
we're going to do
from their bodily fluids a copic test
bro
these people can't even breathe in the
intensive care units i'm talking about
the staff
there's no time there's no nothing
they're not going to be testing every
single cadaver
that comes off the intensive care unit
so you know sometimes people try to
cause a problem when it's not even there
where the solution is not easy
this situation is not easy there are
problems all over the place it doesn't
negate
the issue it that that whether we say a
thousand people died fifteen thousand
people died or
six hundred people died today of covid
it will not change that our intensive
care unit beds
our staff our doctors are in absolute
crisis
that the nurses are absolutely in tears
they cannot
they're all depressed they're all seeing
dead die every single day
they cannot change the fact that i went
to the graveyard and that i
expecting three burials saw 18 burials
and the next day 18 more that is
not a a fake the person who does that is
someone who i trained
he is making it clear to me that on this
year
last year year before this is what the
numbers are
suddenly as a result when what he lied
and their symptoms lied and the fact
that their whole family is infected
that's a lie as well and this person he
couldn't breathe then he died that's a
lie as well and the positive peace
they'll result that's a lie as well
and the guy who's burying the body
that's a lie as well this is
only going to cause a major problem for
the muslims when you're happy that is
is so uh uh uh
dismissive of factual realities this is
what creates cults
this is what skepticism when it's taken
to its wrong level creates
yeah so this is the reason why i came on
a program to make muslims realize
that you cannot have this approach to
life you can't
sorry yeah uh a couple more a couple
more questions [ __ ]
uh some of these uh you might have
answered already but if you did
um tell me it says safe and effective
how are vaccines safe if over 4.6
billion have been paid out of damages
from the vaccine
injury compensation of safe is based
upon a percentage
because of course if you talk about
taking let me just finish the whole
question let me finish the whole
yeah let me finish the whole question uh
compensation and the inserts themselves
indicate a long list of side effects and
risks that include brain damage and
death
how how i'm almost done ask how do
vaccine companies check the safety of
vaccines keep in mind that they
have never done a double-blind placebo
study so what are
they using as a placebo okay so that's
the whole question
first of all that's a complete nonsense
the the the last
just just these three vaccines you can
see
who took the placebo and who didn't take
it we're talking this is a general just
vaccines in general yeah but
it's obviously wrong that part about
this which part is wrong placebo
they didn't use placebo of course they
used placebo and then it says they are
using vaccines or adjuvants such as
aluminum keep in mind they are using
vaccines or adjuvants as aluminum the
definition of placebo
having no aluminum or not aluminum are
you saying
are you saying are you saying like mmr
db all these they do a double blind
placebo or they don't
double blind trials on vaccines
okay today let's talk about today yeah
that are
that are put if they do not use placebo
as their fundamental uh trial
it's not a trial what are you testing if
you don't have a control
i think here here is where like i said
that's just the end part i don't want to
ruin your point
his point so you're saying this is when
you say something is saying okay here
how do we this is a good point right
here because one side is saying
that uh for instance i can this is
independent organization they've sued
actually the companies to show these
tests uh and they they're not using it
you're saying they are so here we go
someone's lying so this is like how do
we because one side is saying everyone
i don't even under you know there's no
double blind placebo
i don't i don't i don't understand
unless we're basically saying that every
single person is lying
right like every person involved every
scientist what if it's proven to you if
it's proven to me
that there was no placebo involved
in mmr or any of these in in in in
in the pfizer in the in the moderna let
me just give an example because
very painfully i watched the independent
uh council of advisory
vaccines go through the flu the data and
i went through it literally with them
if you're telling me that every single
person involved from the scientists to
the company to the now i'm not talking
about no we're not talking about this
new
vaccine for the crime we're talking
about the the mmr all these other
i don't know i i don't know of every
single study
having gone through
so i don't i don't sorry let me repeat
repeat i do not know
the intrinsic details of every clinical
trial that
supported the license of each individual
vaccine
but as a standard as a standard you
would think that there's a double point
against placebo of course because just
usually okay i i
i have to go to cross so you're saying
they are and i get so you're i'm gonna
go back and look what's their evidence
and then
uh this would be like a virtual uh yeah
like i said i'll show your video and
then okay
all right let's go for the next one okay
how are the testings for efficacy
for instance just just on that point
just also also make up makeup make a
point here
sometimes we can also get a bit lost on
this right
so let's imagine let's imagine that uh
and i'm gonna make it clear i don't know
let's just say the mmr or small packs or
smallpox or whatever something previous
in history because i know for certain
that these ones went against this evil
but let's just say that in history in a
historic case
there was a vaccine that didn't go
against placebo
in its testing and it does that to make
sure it's efficacious
and safe that's the reason right yeah
that's the reason you use a placebo
to prove that it works and that it's
safe you agree that's the gold standard
yes
that's right let's say now you you felt
falsified it or you didn't use it or
whatever
and then it comes out and it works and
the data
shows it works and it's safe even if we
assume if we listen to use mmr for
example
and we was to assume that it's true and
it's not the claims
of the figures of autism as a result of
taking it
but let's just say that we assumed it
and we looked at the numbers and we
created the percentages
and it showed that one percent basically
come out with the risk of this
okay then frankly whatever they used in
the clinical trial doesn't matter
because if it's now been going for 10
years right
and you have hundreds and millions now
in your cohort study as opposed to 40
000
your clinical trial and you are now
monitoring all of that
and your data shows that the rate of
measles mumps and rubella has absolutely
plummeted
and it is now very low risk etc etc etc
and the number of autism cases increases
by percentage and then you work out the
sums then it actually doesn't matter now
that doesn't support the idea you should
now go and make drugs without placebo
but it means that whatever happened
historically
here they caught a good bullet you know
they they got away with it
the only thing that should concern us is
now in the current system
any company that wants to prove its
point is gonna obviously have to make it
work against placebo
now when it doesn't it doesn't mean that
it won't work or it's not safe it just
means that there's going to be
far too many questions like for example
modena what a complete
shambles of a clinical trials process
and uh
uh of oxford astrazeneca as well they
know for certain
that oslo ethnic minorities okay pax
black all the rest of it we definitely
have a bigger problem with
with covid than our white you know
anglo-saxon counterparts
okay and yet we will be we became a tiny
minority of the clinical trial cohort
it would have made sense that there will
be more so than more greater data this
is killing far more elderly people than
it is younger people
so you'd expect more elderly to be
involved in the cohort
they won so that shows the poor quality
or we can make excuses
etc etc etc so i'm not supporting all
the clinical trials and giving them you
know
100 as a whatever but at the end of the
day
the data shows that they are safe
efficacious
and so far so good long term allah knows
best
no company is going to say they're 100
safe no person who's a health care
professional should
say that as well there's always
possibility of side effects xyz blah
blah blah
and if you're drinking diet coke don't
ask what's in the flipping vaccine a
couple more questions we'll come to a
close so you mentioned safe down the
next one is on efficacy
because we hear it's safe and effective
so the question uh starts off how are
they
testing for efficacy for instance the
royal medical journal indicated last
january 2020 that the hpv vaccine has
never been tested for efficacy yet they
are vaccinating everyone additionally
vaccine inserts indicate that vaccines
have never been tested
as a carcinogen even though they contain
carcinogens
and have never been tested to see if
they uh they cause infertility
ask him to define efficacy so absolutely
agree efficacy and that's one of the
problems with
um uh uh that's one of the major
uh valid claims against the covert
trials right
um they've said that they're efficacious
that the drug is efficacious 95
but 95 against what and you'll see that
they say serious illness
right or serious symptoms and there'll
be people that argue that that's just
unreal
that's uh not accurate enough that's a
valid point
right how much
better do governments and authorities
want
the people to be to give the the
companies
the the the the the the the
the what the um the framework on which
to actually test their their products
do they want a complete ridding of their
disease
do they want what we call sterilizing
immunity which is that
you might get you know better yourself
but
i just don't want to infect anybody else
at this moment in time
all of the vaccine companies have said
we do not know
we didn't test so i agree entirely the
efficacy
is based upon the definition that the
community the authorities that will come
to
these are our expected goals we just
want people not to die or we just want
people not to have hypoxia or we just
want people not to
have long covert or we just want so
that's a big discussion
completely acceptable the point before
it was what
in the beginning of the question that
the uh met royal
medical journal indicated that uh
january 2020 that the hp vaccine has
never been tested forever oh that's what
i was going to say
yeah i want every bit of date around the
world to say that hpv vaccine is
disaster but don't yeah but that's me
emotionally reacting because i hate that
idea but
yeah okay so now uh we're coming to an
end that's it uh just uh
you're familiar with andrew wakefield if
i was to get him
on the program would you have a 100
grand okay okay that answers that
question you know but the reason i
mentioned
that do you you know andrew wakefield
right
i don't know no i'm saying you know that
the study that
he didn't say that vaccines caused
autism but he had 12 autistic children
and he found inflammation in the gut
and then they cru then then because
doctors use this
every time and i and i heard your video
saying that there is definitely no link
between
autism and and and there is definitely
no statistical proof that from 1 in 10
000 and you're my generation to 1 in 34
in the vaccine generation why did
food allergies suddenly appear in 1989
they're all coming from vaccines and by
the way
it's not just me saying it all those 400
diseases that suddenly became epidemic
after 1989
every one of them is listed as a side
effect it's free of
of a number of factors that creates that
link
that is my scientific opinion and allah
knows best
because once you base your opinions on
statistics
yeah there's always a possibility oh
you have the swelling of the brain the
medical term of the long term
uh ethyl cephalitis uh that's on the
insert
so that equals autism doesn't it and not
necessarily no not every swelling
creates autism i mean obviously they
know that
um listen there's no doubt there's no
doubt that
how do you explain this when the
vaccines went up to 76 doses we saw all
the chronic health
issues also autism just exploded like i
said about an hour ago
i completely agree with this i
completely agree with their point
your point that we live in a world now
where we have and it will be completely
disingenuous to try and make out that
it's vaccines that have caused this
it's the modern world growth it's a
developed world bro it's
our diet it's the way that we live it's
our approach to hygiene
and would i remove would i remove
vaccines from this
absolutely that's fair you're being fair
that's you're not saying like some
people they say
absolutely not but if it's not
once you start dealing in synthetic
products once you're starting dealing
with
you know things that are created in the
laboratory you're obviously
opening the door to the unknown okay now
we can
so i want you to understand listen eddie
listen
all of your people need to understand
that people who are extreme on either
side
you know everybody can see them for a
mile off they just they don't know what
they're talking about
muslims need to appreciate that life is
all about mitigation of risk
our islam teaches us that as a muslim
you look for as much benefit as possible
and you minimize the harm
that you sometimes are put in a
situation where you even have to take a
harmony in that scenario you take the
lesser of the two harms
and this is a basic approach all of life
is mitigation of risk
we do not when we give an apple say that
you know don't enjoy this apple there's
a risk of death we don't go going out
for a walk and say
that there's a 1 in 300 chance that
you're going to fall and you're going to
kill yourself you say
enjoy your walk that's what we say look
my own friends say is that when we take
medicines
we should also put that as part of the
general principles of life
am i happy that we have created a world
where we are dependent upon medication
where it has lowered our threshold to
pain
whereas had a mental effect this had an
internal effect am i happy no i'm not
i decided against myself when i had the
coveted injection divisor one
last thursday my arm was killing
absolutely killing that thursday night
that friday night me being a hero
i was like no you know they were saying
take the paracetamol technical code more
no because i don't want to lower my pain
i've already injected myself
with something that's content into a
monkey and bill gates is going to know
about it i don't now need to also reduce
my threshold
as well so i said no you know what it is
i put up with it it killed me on
saturday and then by saturday night it
was great and my arm is not hurting
anymore there are some people that are
going to say
i don't want to touch or feel pain
whatsoever and they
actually before they take the
vaccination they take the prices more
before so that it can actually cover the
period of any even appearance of pain
they don't want to go anywhere
anyway neither there's a problem there
just just with the process more taking
about the
the lack of exposure to tough
circumstances which a muslim is not
trying to or shouldn't be trying to
avoid in its entirety so there's many
deeper
ethical moral questions about the
philosophy of medicine and vaccines
let alone the scientific discussion
let's learn the islamic
discussion let alone implant
as i said to you the reason i came here
is because muslims
have not liked to turn into conspiracy
theories where their skepticism
has now dominated their trust in allah
and tuata
and unanimity and ishmael and that's a
problem since you mentioned this term
we're done but uh
i'm not a conspiracy theorist it's a
shame we have to just repeat that but
you know
when this term was actually coined in
1974 when people were questioning the
kennedy assassination
to get people from you know questioning
but you had our friend yasha cardi you
know asakardi
he was talking about the german
parliament was bombed
the parliament was bombed a fire was set
up
hitler immediately said the jews did it
instantaneously the public ran with it
the perception was that this is a jewish
plot
and because of this one incident of
bombing the parliament
hitler asked and was given unilateral
powers
like what happened 20 years ago in our
own country because of one terrorist
attack
you do have things that are happening
out there in the world i have no
listen i don't know a conspiracy
theorist itself it depends upon the
conspiracy right
it's a good phrase or not i don't mind
being called the conspiracy theorists
about those things which are to do with
american policy for example
look at iraq for instance and you know
the you know
500 million definition of what
conspiracy means yeah and you know that
the 500
they had the pentagon spent 500 million
to make fake terrorist
videos you know to make us look like
terrorists and that you know and whatnot
so you have things these are
conspiracies that happen
people would call that conspiracy is
that yeah you know my new slogan
you know my new slogan bro because they
say never know
no they say never forget and i say
because every time that year comes
around
more muslims also where muslims also die
say never forget islam and muslims had
nothing to do with 9 11.
stop using us as the scapegoat all right
let me just let me just finish let me
finish here when you mentioned consensus
it just stuck in my mind
you know when we look back consensus we
look at uh at one time there was a
consensus with doctors
who were smoking and they were promoting
cigarettes that cigarettes the consensus
around vaccines is just like tobacco
science you know
would would we have fought for tobacco
science there was a time when every
doctor was saying
smoking cigarettes is good for you or at
least it's not bad for you i mean that
that existed
and the industry was just paying for
tons and tons of science to be done
that supported that issue that's what's
happening in vaccines and then you had a
small group of scientists like
like you do today who were fighting the
consensus but then they actually won you
know
but you had the you had what's up by the
way i wish you used a better example bro
okay any point in history that the
consensus was that the cigarettes were
okay bro come on
then you had in the modern schooling in
your universities there's a consensus
that there's like no god you know what i
mean
so then about that bro come on man
you're using some weak examples
come on then you
and the consensus around you know the
people of his time so that's
so from every two thirds of the the
constitution had the two thirds the
black man was two-thirds of the white
man right
so you had at the one time you had a
consensus they were fighting the muslims
saying that islam is false
so we always had then allah tells us in
the quran doesn't even that you know if
you follow the majority
most of the time you're going to be you
know so now you do have
you do have small groups at times you
have you standing to what consensus
means
so you do have even scientists at one
time galileo galileo right galileo
let me help you yeah you get that point
you get the point right
said the truth is the truth even if you
are alone
upon it so so like i said there is no
hiding
muslims don't hide the the principles
the idea is that there's no doubt a
definition of consensus that there's
something called a silence
silent consensus that there's a a a a an
active one
that consensus can change that there are
certain voices that if they go against
the any
the expected opinion is that then called
or is that ishmael these are technical
discussions what they do not
what they do not affect is the
is the consequence when there is
when there is a a an unacceptable
possibility or the an impossible a a
reality of
everyone colluding together to try and
pull the wool over someone's eyes
and as i said when you take that path
it's a very dangerous one and that's why
i just want to come on here to the
muslims and say that you know what
it's far better for you to you know if
you're worried about your kind of
situation
then don't take the vaccine no problem
but protect your aki the way you start
to question
absolutely every single person and every
single thing and likewise to those who
are pro
everything be very careful about that
that
your akida is not affected by your
scientist or scientific or by your
social or by your muse
based decisions because it's happening
we're muslims ones who have uh by
definition submitted our will to the
creator of the heavens and earth for
those watching who are not yet muslim
because everyone has the potential to
submit to one and only one god
we love you as we love jesus as we love
jesus jesus is one of the greatest
messengers that ever walked
uh on the earth according with uh along
with moses abraham and the last of the
final ministry of prophet muhammad peace
be
upon him so bringing this to a close
we're a holistic people and
in the quran which is the greater word
of god almighty based on proof of
evidence
if we can agree on another thing sheikh
that in the quran chapter 2 verse i
think 172 god almighty
is saying that eat o you who believe eat
of the good things so if we can agree to
this that we can get muslims to get
those coca-colas out of the masjids we
can
stop eating fake food eat real food to
support our immune system the
the the gift that allah gave us that god
almighty gave us
to be able to you know help us in these
things we don't
push away obviously medicines that are
there that you know to tie our camera
understand but
but at the end of the day to really you
know live a holistic life
and you know try to combat obesity and
many of these chronic health issues
by eating real foods the thai bad foods
avoiding fake foods you know taking care
of this gift this vehicle
that allah gave us to get us through
life i mean this is something that
i i try to encourage different scholars
shaykhs to kind of you know to talk more
about this
you know would you agree
that means the organic food that means
the healthy food yes unfortunately means
the expensive food in a lot of times but
it doesn't have to be
and the more that you hang around and
you know uh
i know that eddie spends a lot of time
on this and you know i'm sure that maybe
that's an area as well eddie for a
future show
how to make it affordable how to make it
realistic and not just for folks in the
states
in the international kind of you know
communities it's not an easy game though
okay and uh uh and that definitely
extends to medicines and i wish
even as a pharmacist i wish that we had
a world that was less dependent on
medicines i wish that we could be that
and and that's my general approach and
it's in nine of my islamic teachings i
very strongly hold that people are not
meant to live forever
i'm always being called called all the
time eddie all right let's
cut the jokes all the time my father's
on life support can i take him off take
him off my mother's on life support
we are not people who are dependent upon
this life we have somewhere to go
we don't need to remain in the decrepit
state being fed and injected in iv
god knows what artificial life in
coldness this that whatever whatnot
we are not meant to be relying upon
these medicines to the level that we
don't just tie the camera but we
strangle the damn camera and put them
down in the ground and you know
there is a balance to life um
and very much i agree that we have
created a problem with our approach to
life our diet our medicine approach
and so if a person can avoid for
themselves
to anything not just vaccines but
anything synthetic etc etc
then so be it but let me make it also
very clear as much as i love eddie and
as much as i love all the muslims who
may disagree with me
uh these vaccines are demonstrably safe
they are
beyond the uh the the limits that we
would consider where the risk of them is
greater than the risk which is
happening to those of us of vulnerable
age in the west
okay i'm not that foolish enough to say
that this is what people who are living
in the east who don't even care about it
who don't need hospital beds who are not
dependent upon intensive care units that
are not available for them
that don't have a life that depends upon
that kind of reality that are eating
pure food good food that have good good
immune systems that are not our
vulnerable
co-morbidities are not over 17 80 90
years old
but if you are like in our communities
then it's something which i
promote i am willing to stand and accept
its safety and i will not you know say
that it is
without risk and that is with all
medication all food
and of unfortunately the way that we
live our lives but do i
go back to what eddie said 100 and this
is the deen shown so we should bring it
back down to islam
allah absolutely promoting the pure
and we love the show idea and we love
the fact that we finally got on
and uh uh you know every time that you
mentioned that we always worship allah
and we
worship him like the prophets i always
used to get excited man i love that
behavior so i'm glad that you got those
lines in
even in a boring vaccine talk bro mad
love for you bro
thank you very much it was really nice
talking with you we had a nice healthy
discussion we covered a lot we went way
over time but
a lot of information two hours you've
murdered me here bro
it's 50 grand for this surely i need to
tell the other guy 100 grand i'm going
to be a millionaire soon bro
i got to go back now to dr sherry
tempeni and inshallah we're getting the
money down but they're ready i'm going
to share that with her yeah
shea thank you very much may allah god
almighty the creator of allah bless you
and your family
you as well all right take care of
yourself chicago man shout out to
chicago hey i'm teaching in chicago next
week
oh yeah you got this uh let the people
know you gotta yeah
actually difficult medicines where i
teach people that you shouldn't be
taking medicines willy-nilly
that's actually part of the module of
the class it's the book of death the
pick of sickness the book of health
we go into organ donation we understand
what's going on there all of this kind
of stuff
it's being taught virtually so
almighty.org check it out chicago
chicagoans chica what do you call you
guys
you guys uh chicago chicagoans
and if you like this episode of the deen
show like this video
share this video far and wide and
support us on our patreon page so we can
continue this work
thank you for tuning in peace be with
you assalamu alaikum
subscribe right now